for many they're becoming images from an
almost forgotten era
as winter sunshine abroad's cancelled at
least for the next month
it was disappointing and disheartening
so i think after the year we've had
i think there's one thing i'm looking
forward to sam's supposed to be flying
to gran canaria
two days after national lockdown begins
it's been hard to get outside this year
at all really so like the idea of having
a week
of like outdoor activity just like
completely switched off was
kind of actually lovely like i'm like
it's just really gutted i can't go
an international inessential travel ban
will be in force
unless for work education or other
exemptions
how do you feel about not going on
holiday
you feel sad yeah it means uk
holidays as well emily and percy have
cancelled two
over two lockdowns now the latest to
skegness next week
it's the same four walls every day um
that you're looking at and being with
the same people it's just i do feel fed
up i do i feel really really gutted i
just sort of think
how was my look so bad that two holidays
have been cancelled
as there's two lockdowns but then i just
keep reminding myself this isn't forever
it will decimate the industry once again
amid criticism for the government
adding new travel corridors to the
canaries just last week it's been an
absolutely terrible year for travel and
unlike the hospitality industry we
haven't really had
any opportunity to recover yet because
you talk about these stop start
positions with the
the travel corridors we've lost 90 000
jobs already and we know that there's
more
in the pipeline so it's really important
that the government just look at
bringing in some tailored support for
the travel sector
there'll be a rush for refunds with
concerns some flights still running may
not pay out
the question of when and if to rebook is
for tens of thousands of people
up in the air indefinitely adele
robinson sky news